[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit mitri sirin guten abend der
russland ukraine krieg wieder in unserem
fokus katja dazu gehören auch wieder
sportpolitische entscheidung ja sehr
umstritten handys meisten angst und
verzweiflung bei den kriegs betroffenen
werden immer größer wir sortieren in
unserer sendung wieder die wichtigsten
und aktuellsten entwicklungen
russland sieht weiter vor allem auf die
großen städte raketen schlagen ein die
ukraine zählt mehr als 2000 toten
zivilisten seit beginn des krieges
währenddessen steigt die zahl der
flüchtlinge rasant fast 900.000 menschen
haben das land verlassen
wir schauen nach lemberg einem drehkreuz
für flüchtlinge und vor der uno wird die
deutsche außenministerin berbalk für
eine scharfe verurteilung russlands und
die vollversammlung stimmt mit großer
mehrheit für die historische resolution
es gibt viele tote und verletzte in der
ukraine und es werden immer mehr auch
russland räumt jetzt erstmals hohe
verluste 1 498 tote soldaten fast 1600
verletzte gleichzeitig gibt es massive
fluchtbewegungen aus der ukraine
die zahl der menschen die richtung
westen fliehen steigt laut uno
exponentiell währenddessen greift das
russische militär weiter massiv an mit
raketen und panzern wie zb in hf wurde
der bericht von alexandra vacano und
luton linus beginnt
kharkiv die eben noch pulsierende
universitätsstadt jetzt unter beschuss
seit tagen die zweitgrößte stadt in der
ukraine wohl eines der russischen
hauptziele mit luftangriffen und raketen
ein marschflugkörper schlägt einen das
gebäude des stadtrats vier tote zehn
können gerettet werden für den
bürgermeister ist klar hp wird sich den
russischen truppen nicht ergeben gegen
mittag sprechen wir mit alina in hf sie
hat sich mit ihrer familie im flur ihrer
wohnung verschanzt und dann das
da kommt wieder ein flugzeug
luftangriffe fast in jeder stunde seit
gestern
mit den treppen wollten sie einen
schnellen angriff führen doch das hat
nicht geklappt
jetzt haben sie entschieden alles zu
zerstören so dass uns kein anderer
ausweg bleibt als die kapitulation
bomben und raketen auf rajiv die russen
haben bereits land gewinne bisher nahe
der grenze und außerhalb der städte
luftangriffe auch auf die stadt quito
mir rund 140 kilometer von der
hauptstadt kiew entfernt
wohngebäude und ein krankenhaus seien
getroffen worden so der bürgermeister
nach angaben der behörden werden zehn
verletzt zwei sterben
ich habe meine frau verloren sie war das
licht meines lebens das beste was mir
passieren konnte aber jetzt muss ich
mich zusammenreißen ich habe noch eltern
und eine tochter
vor kiew weiter hinter rund 60 kilometer
lange russische militärkonvoi er bewegt
sich seit tagen weiter auf die
hauptstadt zu währenddessen versuchen
die menschen in kiew am siebten tag des
krieges zu fliehen mit hab und gut über
zerstörte brücken
die die bleiben errichten barrikaden
wir versuchen uns hier selbst zu
organisieren und das dieser abschaum
nicht in unser land kommt wir wissen
nicht wohin wir gehen sollen und haben
es satt uns zu fürchten
durchhalteparolen vom ukrainischen
präsidenten er spricht von 6.000
getöteten russischen soldaten
6000 und wofür um die ukraine
einzunehmen das ist unmöglich das wird
ihnen nicht gelingen
russische angriffe auch auf die städte
im süden mario pohl unter kontrolle
hätten sie bereits die hafenstadt carson
die ukrainische seite bestreitet das
an vielen orten in der ukraine wird
mobilisiert für den kampf männer
zwischen 18 und 60 jahren der widerstand
scheint zu wachsen wie in nrw da wo die
mitarbeiter die zufahrt zu ihrem
atomkraftwerk blockieren
und in kunow top fragt der bürgermeister
wer ist fürs kämpfen die antwort der
menschen lautet kämpfen kämpfen
und wir gehen wieder zu katrin eigendorf
befindet sich circa 300 kilometer
westlich von kiew kathrin es soll jetzt
neue friedensgespräche zwischen russen
und ukrainern geben was es zu erwarten
ja wir hören dass die russische
delegation vor einer halben stunde
eingetroffen ist die ukrainische
delegation noch nicht im moment erwartet
man eigentlich nicht viel denn es sieht
ja so aus dass putin diesen krieg mit
aller brutalität weiterführt es ist
einfach nur ein tor das noch offen ist
das zumindest verhandlungen
weitergeführt werden aber wenn man sich
die situation heute hier anguckt ich
ihnen mal ein beispiel uns hat gerade
die nachricht erreicht von kontakt
unseren kontakt mehr hieß da ist ein
blindenheim mit kindern getroffen worden
dass es komplett lahmgelegt worden sie
sind von der versorgung abgeschnitten
das sind nachrichten die hier überall
auch durch die sozialen medien
verbreitet werden das macht die leute so
wütend und so bitter und auch die
menschen mit denen wir hier heute
gesprochen haben die sind an diesem
siebten tag des krieges einfach auch ja
mittlerweile so verbittert und wütend
dass sie eigentlich im moment gar keine
großen hoffnungen mehr an solche
gespräche knüpfen
ja das ist das was ich dazu sagen kann
wie lange heute hier aussieht schlimme
nachrichten bleibt vorsichtig dankeschön
kathrin so viel scheint klar russland
hat sich den militäreinsatz offenbar
anders vorgestellt inzwischen ist moskau
von wenigen ländern abgesehen
international ziemlich isoliert die
sanktionen werden immer spürbarer und
die wenigen unabhängigen
pressevertretern russland werden immer
schärfer attackiert beziehungsweise
mundtot gemacht kulinart über einen
russland das diesen angriffskrieg in den
staatsmedien nur
spezialoperationen nennt
nur noch ein rauschen ist zu hören auf
der welle auf der über 30 jahre lang
radio echo moskwy ausgestrahlt wurde der
einzig verbliebene landesweite
rundfunksender dennoch nicht gänzlich
unter kreml kontrolle war in den büros
liegen beruhigungsmittel auf den
schreibtischen
chefredakteur alexej venedig dorf will
vor gericht ziehen zensur sagt er sei
doch laut verfassung verboten
ich bin überrascht immer noch überrascht
nein das hat er absolut niemand erwartet
wir haben auf ein paar unabhängige
medien aber ich glaube sie stehen auch
vor dem aus
inzwischen ist ein weiteres online
medium blockiert ein weiterer
hörfunksender hat beschlossen seine
sendungen einzustellen weil er so
wörtlich nicht lügen will als regional
zeitungen gestern dieser wahnsinn muss
gestoppt werden auf den titelseiten
brachten wurden sie beschlagnahmt
ich finde das ungeheuerlich das sind
doch die überreste einer freien stimme
die erstickt wurden
wahrscheinlich sagen sie zu viel von dem
was nicht gewünscht wird zensur hat
gestern verhaftete die polizei zwei
mütter und ihre fünf kinder die blumen
niederlegen wollten an der ukrainischen
botschaft sie trugen plakate mit der
aufschrift kein krieg den eltern wird
gedroht die vormundschaft für die kinder
zu entziehen
[Musik]
trotzdem findet der protest der bürger
wege sich auszudrücken der slogan kein
krieg schmückt inzwischen häuserwände
bushaltestellen balkongeländer und
fahrstühle auch wenn er schnell übermalt
wird
wir fragen weiter nach bei christian
slam in moskau der in russischer haft
sitzende oppositionelle navalny hat sich
wieder gemeldet ruft zu protesten auf
christian was können sie uns darüber
sagen
ja genau alexej nawalny hat das über
seine anwälte und über die social media
kanäle gemacht und hat heute zu
protesten in mehreren großen russischen
städten aufgerufen und die soll es jetzt
jeden tag gehen geben er sagt die
menschen sollen jeden abend um 19 uhr
auf die straße gehen auf die zentralen
plätze ihrer städte und protestieren
heute abend in moskau was wir sehen uns
ein großes polizeiaufgebot ein großes
aufgebot an sicherheitskräften viele
polizeitransporter haben sich bereit
gemacht und in moskau war es ruhig dort
haben wir nicht viele menschen auf der
straße gesehen anders siehts aus in
sankt petersburg da erreichen uns bilder
dass mehrere hundert menschen auf der
straße waren zumindest eine kurze zeit
und dann wieder sich die masse
verflüchtigt hat man muss jetzt sehen ob
der aufruf von alexei navalny nachhaltig
wirkung hat denn bislang hat das den
demonstranten gefehlt ein prominenter
kopf der zu den protesten aufruft und
wir erinnern uns an frühere jahre hier
in moskau und in russland auch wenn das
einer geschafft hat dann war das
tatsächlich alexej nawalny vielen dank
nach moskau christiansen eingangs
erwähnt die zahl der flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine steigt weiter deutlich fast
900.000 menschen haben das land nach
un-angaben bereits verlassen in der
ukraine geht es für viele dann erst
einmal in das relativ sichere lemberg im
westen des landes sie hoffen züge zu
bekommen nach polen aber auch nach
ungarn und in die slowakei über die
situation am bahnhof in lemberg
berichtet jetzt armin coerper
manchmal bricht sich die erschöpfung
bahn in gesichtern die sie nicht mehr
zeigen wollen oder können lembeck
hauptbahnhof immer enger wird das
nadelöhr zur sicherheit weil eben so
viele reihen wie raus wollen bewegt sich
fast nichts was ihn und seine freundin
laden wenigstens die telefon batterien
sind studenten aus indien in rackith
einer stadt seit tagen unter beschuss
wir sind sieben kilometer zum bahnhof
gelaufen im zug haben wir gestanden weil
es keinen platz gab es dreizehn oder
vierzehn stunden lang
gestern sind die raketen direkt über
meinen kopf geflogen gleich vor dem
bahnhof
in den zelten des roten kreuzes sind die
die hilfe am nötigsten brauchen menschen
wie ludmilla die mit ihrer tochter im
rollstuhl seit gestern auf der flucht
ist wir kommen aus raumschiff wir würden
dort beschossen und haben solche angst
bitte bitte stoppt diesen krieg
während die zerstörung und die angriffe
durch die russischen streitkräfte im
osten und im zentrum des landes stetig
zunehmen kommt der konflikt immer näher
in richtung westen denn die menschen
hier haben wenig im gepäck außer der not
und der verzweiflung durch krieges
während wir am bahnhof sind ertönen in
der ganzen stadt wieder die sirenen
bombenalarm doch die die es bislang berg
geschafft haben hören nicht mehr hin
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
und auch jenen auf der flucht helfen
wollen dann können sie spenden zum
beispiel beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 und alle
infos dazu auch spenden zdf.de und auf
der zdf textseite 890
außenminister sind chefdiplomaten ihrer
länder und müssen die kunst beherrschen
mit vielen worten klartext zu vermeiden
aber das was außenministerin berber
gestern abend vor der un vollversammlung
sprach war an klartext kaum zu
überbieten sie warf moskau dreiste lügen
vor sehr deutlich war auch das ergebnis
der abstimmung über eine resolution die
den angriffskrieg russlands scharf
verurteilt 141 mitgliedsstaaten der
vereinten nationen stimmten dafür 35
länder enthielten sich und nur fünf
lehnten den beschluss ab aus new york
johannes hano
praktisch in letzter minute hat in
deutschland noch einmal sein ganzes
diplomatisches gewicht in die waagschale
geworfen und die aussenministerin
geschickt um die zu überzeugen die sich
noch unschlüssig waren
russland krieg markiert eine neue
realität die verlangt von jedem
einzelnen von uns eine klare und
verantwortungsvolle entscheidung zu
treffen und sich für eine seite zu
entscheiden
bei russlands angriff auf die ukraine
geht es um sehr viel mehr so die
außenministerin es sei ein angriff auf
die charta der vereinten nationen und
die weltordnung die sie repräsentiert
russland hat diese weltordnung brutal
angegriffen und deshalb geht es in
diesem krieg nicht nur um die ukraine
sondern uns alle russlands krieg
markiert den anbruch einer neuen ära es
ist ein wendepunkt
und sie macht den eindringlichen worten
klar was dieser krieg bedeutet
es geht um leben oder tod des
ukrainischen volkes
es geht um die sicherheit europas auf
dem spiel steht die charta der vereinten
nationen
fast jedes in diesem raum vertretene
land hat einen grösseren mächtigeren
nachbarn es geht um uns alle
am ende gab es was in der
generalversammlung so gut wie nie
vorkommt beifall für eine rede die von
vielen diplomaten als außergewöhnlich
stark betrachtet wurde
gehen wir live nach new york zu johannes
hano es ist eine historische resolution
wie ist es dieses abstimmungsergebnis zu
deuten johannes
also wirklich niemand hier hatte mit
einem so hohen zustimmung zu dieser
resolution gerechnet dass es einmalig in
der geschichte der vereinten nationen
dass so viele staaten an dass solche
resolution zugestimmt haben allerdings
gibt es auch einen wermutstropfen dass
nämlich länder wie china und indien 2
atommächte sich der stimme enthalten
haben das würde zeigen wie es um die
welt bestellte sagt uns ein diplomat
nach der abstimmung ihr gerade noch mal
klar ist aber auch russland hat sein
ziel nicht erreicht die zustimmung so
gering wie möglich zu halten nur vier
freunde wenn man so will russlands haben
mit russland gestimmt weißrussland
syrien nordkorea und eritrea und das
sagt ja auch eine ganze menge aus diese
resolution ist jetzt nicht rechtlich
binden aber unpolitisch von großer
bedeutung russland wird weiter isoliert
und das kann man auch daran sehen dass
selbst ein land wie serbien für diese
resolution gestimmt hat das sich sonst
sehr eng mit russland abspricht danke
nach new york johannes hano bleiben wir
in den usa in washington hat präsident
biden in seiner rede zur lage der nation
den russischen präsidenten putin scharf
angegriffen putin sei ein diktator der
die westlichen staaten spalten wolle
aber der zusammenhalt sei groß putin
dagegen international isoliert wie nie
zuvor so beiden der us luftraum werde
für russische flugzeuge gesperrt
außerdem kündigte er ein härteres
vorgehen gegen russische oligarchen an
ein termin war kanzler scholz heute so
wichtig dass er ihn trotz des krieges
wahrgenommen hat seinen antrittsbesuch
in israel
denn natürlich auch vom thema ukraine
überschattet war scholz und der
israelische regierungschef bennett
forderten einen waffenstillstand und
verhandlungen klar position beziehen im
konflikt will israels regierung aber
nicht michael lieferung
yad vashem das bedeutet verantwortung
für die vergangenheit aber eben auch
verantwortung für die gegenwart olaf
scholz bekommt das beim besuch der
holocaust-gedenkstätte hautnah zu spüren
auch in der nähe von babi jar bei kiew
dem ort des größten massaker an juden im
zweiten weltkrieg fielen gestern
russische bomben kein vergleich aber
doch eine parallele zu hitlers krieg
natürlich erwächst aus unserer
geschichte auch eine verantwortung für
eine friedensordnung in europa zu werben
die kriege
ausschließt
deutschland hat eine wende in der
ukraine politik vollzogen liefert waffen
trägt schärfste sanktionen mit scholz
setzt nur eine grenze heute wir werden
nicht militärisch eingreifen
das gilt für die nato das wird sie nicht
tun
und so auch für alle andern
israel liefert keine waffen verhängt
keine sanktionen nicht mal den
angriffskrieg russlands will das
verurteilen wir
fordern einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand in der ukraine und wir
identifizieren uns mit den bürgern in
großer gefahr und not bestätigt der
ministerpräsident ganz lapidar
israel leistet nur humanitäre hilfe will
russland nicht vergraulen das spielt als
schutzmacht syriens eine starke rolle im
nahen osten vermittelt hier und da für
israel in syrien und gase realpolitik
ist eben oft stärker als historische
verantwortung
desinformation und propaganda gehören in
einem krieg zum waffenarsenal in der eu
sind die russischen staatsmedien rt und
sputnik deshalb ab sofort verboten
russland diktiert seinen medien nämlich
wie sie diesen krieg zu sehen haben und
dass sie keinesfalls von einem krieg
sprechen dürfen die wahrheit suchen
viele russen in diesen tagen vor allem
im internet wo es wenig überraschend
reichlich propaganda gibt was die
netzwerke dagegen tun zeigt uns jetzt
wenn regen
diese bilder hat der meta konzern schon
immer gern gezeigt der kampf gegen fake
news verschwörungstheorien und
propaganda geführt von einer großen news
feed redaktion doch bislang so betonen
kritiker immer wieder gegen der profit
vor das hat sich mit dem stricken
ausgrenzen von inhalten aus russland
jetzt offenbar geändert also die
technologie hat schon existiert so habe
das immer die frage wo kann ich geld
verdienen wobei natürlich die
algorithmen darauf gestrickt waren auf
kontroverse inhalte zu leiten um eben
dieses engagement also die interaktion
zu fördern russland hat seinerseits den
zugang zu facebook instagram und twitter
gesperrt also nicht gefiltert sondern
ausgegrenzt das hält allerdings
russische computernetzwerke nicht davon
ab immer wieder neue inhalte zu posten
um einen möglichst großen effekt zu
haben brauche ich eben möglichst viele
accounts möglichst viele pots und das
schafft man natürlich dann wenn man
besonders große finanzielle mittel
einsetzt russland wendet diese mittel
schon seit jahren auf auch beim aufbau
von auslands tv sendern auch darauf
reagieren jetzt die plattformbetreiber
rt deutsch muss seinen live stream
abschalten uns ist auch per youtube
nicht mehr zu erreichen die gesteuerte
indirekte verbreitung über netzwerke wie
telegramm geht trotzdem weiter und man
glaubt gewissermaßen man erfährt etwas
das alle anderen auch erfahren und in
wirklichkeit hat man aber zielgerichtet
unterschiedlichen menschen
unterschiedliche informationen gegeben
und damit dass information betrieben
youtube und twitter drehen russischen
anbietern zudem den geldhahn zu
werbeerlöse auch durch unproblematische
inhalte werden nicht mehr ausgezahlt
damit so die hoffnung fehlt bald ein
teil des geldes für die propaganda
wieder ein starkes zeichen aus
deutschland gegen den krieg in münchen
haben sich zur stunde mehrere
zehntausend menschen auf dem königsplatz
versammelt um gegen die russische
invasion und für solidarität mit der
ukraine zu demonstrieren zu der
kundgebung haben fast alle parteien und
zahlreiche verbände aufgerufen
zum krieg in der ukraine auch heute
wieder ein zdf spezial gleich hier im
anschluss und zu jeder zeit auf dem
letzten stand der ereignisse und
entwicklungen sind sie mit unserem live
blog in der zdf- heute- app
ein blick jetzt auf den arbeitsmarkt der
befindet sich weiter im aufwärtstrend
mögliche folgen des krieges spiegeln die
zahlen laut bundesagentur allerdings
noch nicht wieder im februar waren zwei
millionen
428.000 menschen ohne job das sind 34
1000 weniger als im januar die
arbeitslosenquote liegt bei 5,3 prozent
im vergleich zum februar letzten jahres
gibt es
476.000 weniger arbeitslose
fünf monate hatte sich der kölner
kardinal woelki eine auszeit genommen
heute hat er sein amt wieder angetreten
und dem papst überraschend seinen
rücktritt angeboten franziskus werde zu
gegebener zeit darüber entscheiden
teilte das erzbistum mit vor dem kölner
dom hat es am morgen proteste gegen
woelkis rückkehr gegeben der 65 jährige
steht massiv in der kritik wegen seines
umgangs mit missbrauchsfällen in der
katholischen kirche in einem brief an
die gläubigen bad woelki um eine zweite
chance und
wir schauen nach australien erhalten die
heftigen regenfälle weiter an sydney
bereitet sich auf das schlimmste vor
schon jetzt stehen teile der stadt unter
wasser eine sturmfront mit starkregen
hatte zunächst eben bundesstaat
queensland überschwemmungen verursacht
danach traf in new south wales in
einigen gegnern hatte es innerhalb
weniger tage so viel geregnet wie sonst
in einem jahr ganze orte wurden
überflutet mindestens 13 menschen kamen
bislang ums leben
und noch eine traurige nachricht gerade
für uns hier in der heute redaktion
claus seibel der mehr als drei
jahrzehnte lang dieser sendung moderiert
hat ist gestorben er wurde 85 jahre alt
sein gesicht wird in erinnerung bleiben
so zdf-chefredakteur frei sein stil
zurückhaltender verbindlichkeit setzt
maßstäbe bis heute ein nachruf von
christoph distel die nachrichten des
tages heute mit klaus seiten verehrte
zuschauer guten abend ein bisschen
wohnte er mit in den deutschen
wohnzimmern 32 jahre lang gesicht stimme
all das gehört dazu wenn er punkt 19 uhr
die welt für seine zuschauer sortierte
zum allerersten mal der wetter kollege
hantierte noch mit kreidetafeln im juli
es war schrecklich weil ich das gefühl
hatte jetzt geht der bricht der boden
unter der weg lampenfieber obwohl er mit
radio erfahrung zu heute kam übrigens
direkt an 370 mitbewerbern vorbei hab da
hieß es auf sendung um 7 egal was
passiert beste bedingungen für den zitat
seibel er faulen menschen doch ich
brauche den druck braucht den druck der
usa funktioniere ich einfach nicht denn
wohlgemerkt 19 uhr war nicht etwa sein
dienst beginnt sondern fast schon
feierabend für ihn als redakteur im
studio wie das damals hieß das davor das
war seine leidenschaft nachrichten
gewichten an texten feilen mit anderen
an der sendung bauen sehr professionell
und wer dabei war weiß dass
grundsätzlich gut gelaunt
jetzt gibt es einen schnitt in unserer
sendung wir machen mit sport und mit
katja stresow war das internationale
paralympische komitee hat heute
entschieden dass russische und
belarussische athletinnen und athleten
an den am freitag beginnenden
paralympics teilnehmen dürfen eine
entscheidung die viele fassungslos und
wütend zurück lässt ein dunkler schleier
lag heute über den proben zur
eröffnungsfeier entgegen mehrheitlicher
meinung dürfen belarussische und
russische athleten unter auflagen an den
paralympics teilnehmen sie werden unsere
der paralympischen flagge und hymne
antreten aber sie werden nicht im
medaillenspiegel auftauchen
wegen dopings musste russland schon 2018
bei den spielen in korea unter der
paralympischen flagge antreten doch
jetzt ist kein doping jetzt ist krieg
sie starten für länder die aktuell im
krieg sind morgen leute erschießen das
ist so unerträglich
noch bemerkenswerter ist die
unterstützung und anteilnahme mit der
die bedrohte ukrainische mannschaft nun
in peking bedacht wird
ich freue mich ihnen mitteilen zu können
dass das ukrainische team vor wenigen
stunden heil und gesund in peking
gelandet ist
die paralympics haben noch gar nicht
begonnen und doch leiden sie jetzt schon
unter einer tonnenschweren politischen
last
heute abend spielen sechs mannschaften
um den einzug ins dfb pokal halbfinale
bereits geschafft und das erstmals seit
21 jahren wieder hat das gestern abend
union berlin durch ein 2 1 gegen st
pauli
noch ein schritt bis berlin verbunden
mit der kurzen anreise union steht im
halbfinale des dfb pokals
zwar geht der zweitligist st pauli durch
diesen treffer von piero und torwart
fehler von renault in führung doch kurz
vor der pause gelingt becker am
schrauben torhüters marsch vorbei der
ausgleich in der 75 minute nutzte
eingewechselt zuvor gesagt den
ausrutscher und verteidige medi zum 2 2
1 -endstand die elf von urs fischer ist
unter den letzten vier und
werden auch lust aufs skispringen hat
die frauen springen gerade ganz aktuell
zu sehen auf zdf sportstudio punkt de
bzw in der mediathek danke katja und wir
haben noch die lottozahlen für sie und
die gehen so
35 15 39 44 49 und die superzahl 7
weitere gewinnzahlen auf otto.de und auf
der zdf textseite 557
morgen wieder viel sonne allerdings
stellenweise nebel und hochnebel details
gleich von katja horneffer neueste
information ab 21.45 mit marietta slomka
im heute-journal vielen dank fürs
zuschauern vom gesamten heute 19 team
und gleich weiter mit einem zdf spezial
zur lage in der ukraine
guten abend von uns
[Musik]
guten abend auch heute schien die sonne
zum teil wieder strahlend die
nebelfelder hier in schleswig-holstein
lösten sich bis zum späten nachmittag
auf auch in süddeutschland wurden die
wolken immer dünner nur in baden
württemberg blieben sie noch etwas
dichter und die beschäftigen uns dort
auch noch in der nacht sonst ist es
meist klar und in norddeutschland bildet
sich nebel und hochnebel
und es wird wieder cup auf den
ostfriesischen inseln sinken die
temperaturen auf plus 1 grad bis minus
neun grad geht es runter hier im
thüringer wald auch im oberpfälzer wald
oder im erzgebirge morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen am alpenrand am main
und rhein und westlich davon bei 10 bis
14 grad dass es fast schon frühlingsbild
meist aber sind es nur 6 bis 9 grad und
hier an der ostsee bleibt es zum teil 3
bis 5 grad kalt das passiert genau dann
wenn sich nebel und hochnebel dort nicht
auflösen den ganzen tag über nicht das
könnte zum beispiel in der lübecker
bucht passieren sonst aber setzt sich
doch meist und zwar strahlend die sonne
durch und scheint wirklich von morgens
bis abends von ostfriesland bis zum
alpenrand ungestört so ähnlich geht es
dann auch in den nächsten tagen weiter
dabei ist es im osten immer kälter als
im westen genannt